the president was in the Middle East
last week and I actually thought it was
a pretty great trip he he talked about
Palestinian statehood he swage some of
the Israeli fears he got Israel and
Turkey to hug again I thought it all
look good but the polls are just showing
the more and more hate coming out of the
Middle East nobody likes them it's worse
now actually than it was under george w
bush Rick how is this possible Obama how
could this be
the relentlessness of a quote-unquote
media counter media that can lie and
there's no law stopping them from doing
it and just feed incorrect data get
everyone addicted to how they feed it so
they're really defending how that news
makes them feel rather than the beats
and the details right so you're talking
about our media here or you know I'd say
a certain particular network ah that has
there any reason you know overseas
overseas rooted influence that is here
now from oh I don't know say Australia
oh they're gonna spin because you know
as we all know Barack Obama is a Muslim
so how is this how is this working
exactly right well you could tell he's
the devil from that artwork on there
it's not liking him right now
and he's even got a nice middle name you
know that they like love who sings they
love it so I'm really I'm just fastened
I want to maybe I will even watch Fox
this weekend to see how they spin all of
this in their direction yeah but you
know what I don't think it's Barack
Obama personally I think it is the way
that this region is going down right now
things are once again really falling
apart they are there's no stability in
the region there's very little stability
and that's a good thing in some ways but
when you get that you get a lot of
extremists and nationalists and the
Nationalists don't want anything to do
with America yeah is it is it just
endless because if he can't do it if we
can all agree he's done some good things
I mean you know Turkey and Israel hadn't
talked in five years he got them to make
up so if he can't do it is it is it
truly just you know no hammer first
leader can do it yeah if you're coming
on bum bum bum and you're knocking on
the door with a hammer and they're
looking little thing and they see you
knocking on the door with a hammer
they're not as willing to open the door
right and we knock everything with a
hammer when we come knocking yeah we let
everybody know who we really are boom
boom them a little bit you know yeah and
everyone now is very wary of us globally
because of that you know is there
anything we can do now would be what
could we do that would be less hammer
it's like having a friend who's in
crisis you know until your friend really
wants some help then you know what are
you gonna do you can knock on the door
all you want you know the region is in
major transition I think it's gonna take
10-15 years for the region to figure out
what they're doing the moderates of that
region need to come alive in a
democratic way you know as much as these
other groups have come up in these these
tribal you know rivalries are clearly
alive too but you know the moderates
have to come up and find some consensus
then they can reach out to the big
powers like Russia and America and stuff
and get some get some help that way but
you know we I mean they're part of the
reason the regions in the state it's in
is because for the 50 60 years of last
century we went in with hammers there
right and let's construct this and
imagine what the world would look like
right now if there was no oil under all
that dirt would that place be about if
there was nothing we wanted under this
and that's great tourism I mean this is
like we're the you know civilization
began the Fertile Crescent there's such
enormous importance for Humanity and we
ignore all of that because it is all
about the oil so it's all about the oil
we all say that all the time so what so
is the only option we just got to keep
getting greener is that is that what you
think we should do do you have a Chevy
Volt that's what I'm asking all right I
just get a long cord yeah but I'd say
our culture has to start to wean off
something that's finite at some point
the sea species has to get a
away from a finite thing yeah well to
the infinite thing right well they like
doesn't stop but next we'll be watching
it we'll figure out a way to soon enough
it'll be water wars so that's right yeah
yeah we have that to look forward to
with next 90 years actually I'm pretty
sure the water wars have already started
in the Middle East so yeah I'm pretty
sure all the corporations are buying and
this is what they're doing they're
Butler's privatization of water rights
that's what's already going already
happened
don't forget bonobos com is the official
outfitter of the Reuben report they've
got great new slim fit shirts I've never
felt sharper enter code TR RT 0 for 20%
off your first purchase